Ministry of Health says at least ten
people have been injured in protests at
five different points up and down the
separation fence which splits Gaza from
Israel in the protests that have been
held today the latest protest is part of
the great march of return but the crowds
here much smaller than we've seen in the
past and perhaps that's surprising
because just a week ago Gaza and Israel
were firing rockets at each other to the
south of where I'm standing now a 27
year old Palestinian man was killed in
that exchange of fire but it's
interesting to note that very shortly
after that rocket attack the Israeli
government put out a statement saying
that it held the leader of a single
Islamic Jihad group in Gaza responsible
for that attack it didn't blame anybody
else it just specified this particular
leader spool on a few days and on
Wednesday a delegation from Hamas went
to Cairo Egypt is a key negotiator in
this fragile ceasefire that exists
between Gaza and Israel and the belief
here in Gaza is that Hamas was keen to
show the Egyptians that they were still
committed to the peace process to the
ceasefire that has been continuing on
between Gaza and Israel now if you take
both of those events together you get a
sense that both sides are trying very
hard to keep control of the situation
and run keep the risk of violence very
low the reason for this could be
political Israel is in the process of
trying to pull together our government
and the Palestinians for the first time
since 2006 are going to be voting in
elections as well no date for those
elections has been organized and has
been negotiation about the format of
what is going to happen but there is a
belief here in Gaza that Hamas is trying
to impress on people that it's being the
controlling party in Gaza has control of
security here as well and that's very
important of course in the run-up to
these elections